the brain only learns by only we only
see reality based on pattern recognition
i memorize your face now i know lewis
and if the pattern matches i know
but if you're creating a future and
you're not clear on that future and you
want all these things but you haven't
addressed all those circuits and
behaviors and emotions and chemicals of
the past you won't recognize the pattern
you'll walk right past the relationship
you'll never see it so
so i think that there's the preparation
for the relationship
the overcoming
and overcoming and overcoming and
overcoming and overcoming and becoming
all of a sudden now says i am worthy and
the universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving so when you're
worthy to receive it's not going to be
on match.com when you're looking at body
parts and whatever else this is going to
be like
energy
wow like
that came out of nowhere because
when you're in survival
and you're in separation and you're in
lack and you're forcing and controlling
and trying to predict outcomes your
matter trying to change matter and of
course it's going to take time for this
to happen because you're creating a
three-dimensional reality and everything
in three-dimensional reality takes
time but when you're creating from the
heart with a coherent brain and a
coherent heart and you've got that 5g
wi-fi signal
it's it's not like you go anywhere now
the experiences are coming to you're
drawing the event to you so
so we spend a lot of time
[Music]
bonding with our future emotionally i
have colleagues of mine who look at our
our data on oxytocin and they're like uh
listen oxytocin levels go up during uh
you know when i'm in a relationship the
honeymoon stage of relationship and
monogamy is created because of those
chemicals or
a female mammal is bonding with our
offspring that's exactly right i want
our people our students to bond
and fall in love with their future just
like they do with somebody else and when
you're bonded to your future
no person no circumstance no thing is
going to remove you from it so then if
you fall from grace during the day
then the next question is what person
what circumstance caused me to
disconnect
from my love in the future
and let me rehearse in my mind if i have
that same circumstance how i'm going to
overcome it open your eyes and be in the
initiation of life and stay in that
place and just know that your future is
going to happen so
so
being able to activate the heart and
breathe in there and get the body out of
survival
and start working with it like it feels
safe enough to create once energy makes
it here you're going to get some really
good ideas you're going to see things
you never thought of seeing you're going
to feel things you never thought you'd
feel and the
the images that you're creating what are
they doing the thoughts that you're
creating they're making more of those
chemicals and now you're feeling more of
the feeling of your future before it
happens you're giving your body a
sampling
a taste of the future before it's
happened keep doing that enough times
and that feeling is going to become very
familiar to you there was a researcher
out of yale university that in the 1940s
that was studying electromagnetic fields
around living organisms
and in 1940s and at yale university
nobody was doing this and he was a
vitalist he wanted to understand the
unseen fields around living organisms
so
he started studying eggs
all kinds of eggs chicken eggs swallow
eggs reptile eggs snake eggs salamander
exos all kinds of eggs
and he was using a magnetometer and what
he found was what a hundred percent of
the time
no matter what a he measured the
positive charge was always at the head
and the negative charge was always at
the tail
well if you have positive charge on one
end the negative charge on the other end
you've got a external electromagnetic
field called the magnetic field that's a
magnet right what happens with human
beings
is every thought has a frequency every
thought produces a chemical
so if you keep obsessing
about your lack your lack of finances
your lack of time your lack of energy
lack lack and
those thoughts i don't have this
what are the chemicals you're feeding
your body you're taking thought
it's producing a frequency and that
frequency in the form of chemistry is
storing that thought emotionally right
in your second center you feel guilty
you feel unhappy the moment you feel
unhappy then you generate more thoughts
equal to that feeling which makes more
chemicals and you keep taking energy
from the brain and storing it in the
body
if you react to people in your life and
you feel anger frustration whether it's
traffic the news whatever it is
parents whatever you're drawing from
this field
this electromagnetic field you're
tapping that resource
and you're making chemistry out of it
and the field shrinks so now
by doing that and living in survival
the body no longer is a magnet so now
you have very little energy in the brain
in fact five percent of the energy is in
the brain
then 95 is stored in the body now the
body's been conditioned emotionally so a
lot of energy in the body very little in
the brain focus on what you want and
you'll get more of it and that is
actually true whatever you focus on
you move towards which is why it is so
important to focus on what you want
and do not focus on what you don't want
after all if you were having an
injection in your arm and you look at it
and think about it it's more painful
than if you read a message on your phone
and take your attention elsewhere so i
absolutely believe and science has
proven that when you focus on something
you go towards it
but the thing i think
lets people down in the law of
attraction is that it doesn't ever talk
about application it kind of says you
want the best partner in the world focus
on it think about it imagine they're
there and they will turn up and i'm like
well not really
if you never leave the couch how are
they going to turn up you see if i want
a new home
i can think about the home i want i can
imagine but i also know i've got to go
and look at it i've got to go on to
websites and look at homes and then go
and view that home if i wanted a new job
i can think about the new job imagine
the new job and believe i can manifest
it but
i also need to apply for that new job go
for interviews put myself out there
let's imagine you want the career of
your dreams or maybe you want to start
your own business and that's all good
and you can use the law of attraction to
visualize the career of your dreams to
visualize someone
funding your business setting up your
startup and it's a great visualization
you can use vision boards you can use
meditation
you can use so many things to excite
your imagination to fire off those
neurons and go hey i can do this but you
still
have to take action
the best plan in the world may not work
if you don't work too you see i had an
idea to write a book and i knew i was
going to sit down and write a book and i
did sit down and write a book but i had
to also
find an agent speak to people i was very
lucky that as i was beginning to write
my book i went to a dinner party sat
next to someone happened to be
an agent which was very useful
and then i started to tell one of my
clients i was writing a book and she
said you know the best agent in town
is one of your patients i'm like really
oh yeah so i contacted him he came to my
house he ended up being my agent but i
also had to do work i had to write that
book i had to have the confidence it was
an amazing book
and agents will tell people go oh hey i
could do a harry potter i've written a
book here it is and they go actually no
it's not quite right beside you are
worth it that is so important
it's one of the most but not the most
important step decide you're worth it
and then decide what you are going to do
to get it what are the steps you are
going to take
to make that law of attraction real
what are you going to do if you hit a
roadblock
and the first thing you hear is no
so remember you must take the action you
must be committed you must be
disciplined you must have belief
and faith and a very strong work ethic
too because the best plan in the world
may not work
if you don't work with it once you start
appreciating your boss your clients
they appreciate you back so uh in my 20s
the reason why i i was successful
was i was little uh unique
in so many different different things
for example when i was doing accounting
consulting i divided my uh clients to
two groups one i do regular job the
other i always
bring something whenever i got to meet
them just a herb tea japanese tea like a
book or just not super expensive
so in six months i got so many referrals
from the the gift giving groups you know
i didn't ask for any clients right but
they gave me uh so many referrals and
the second you know a group uh not so
much so i
recommend everybody to start giving more
something a little extra nuts like 30
percent more but something to to show
appreciation and
it doesn't really matter if you're
florist or cleaners or
business lawyers or a dentist if you
start giving something you get more so
this is the law i think if you give more
um you receive more and then
there's one more extra reason to
appreciate about so you you your life
would shift so your whole energy would
be so different and so content and i
think people want to do business with
happier people you know people don't
want to go with people who are very
depressed
so the people with the radiance of
appreciation often attracts more people
and more opportunities so this is not a
new age or a spiritual thing it's a
practice to to um to appreciate more so
what you appreciate appreciates and i
think it's it's so simple so start
appreciating about money is the first
step and then
second step is start appreciating what
you have
and if you start sharing what you have i
call it gift all of us have gifts i've
written probably like
half of my books 20 books on how to
discover your gifts and monetize them
because
we're born each of us is born with a
special gift and something to be shared
with this
planet and if you can find it and if you
can uh improve it and you can you can
polish it and just
share with a society i think
that translates into money so i wrote a
national bestseller
do what you love and make sure money
follows you so it's very important you
have to have both never create
prosperity by talking or thinking about
your lack of money this is wasted
thinking and cannot bring you abundance
dwelling on lack only creates more lack
poverty thinking brings more poverty and
gratitude thinking brings abundance
there are a few affirmations and
attitudes that are guaranteed to keep
prosperity beyond reach
resenting other people for the amount of
money they may have just puts up a wall
between you and your own flow
open your consciousness to new ideas
about money
and it will be yours
there is never enough money now that is
a terrible affirmation to use also the
one money goes out faster than it comes
in this is poverty thinking of the worst
kind
the universe can only respond to what
you believe about yourself and about
life if you think that winning the
lottery will solve all of your problems
you are greatly mistaken because it
doesn't involve changing consciousness
in effect you're saying to the universe
i don't deserve to have good in my life
except by a fluke chance
if you would only change your
consciousness your thinking to allow the
abundance of the universe to flow
through your experience
you could have all the things you think
the lottery can bring you
and you'd be able to keep them because
they would be yours by right of
consciousness
affirming declaring deserving and
allowing are the steps to demonstrating
riches far greater than you could ever
win in a lottery
another thing that can keep you from
prospering is being dishonest
whatever you give out in life comes back
to you always
and if you take from life then life will
take from you it is that simple
you may feel that you don't steal but
are you counting the paper clips and
stamps you may take from the office
or are you a person who steals time
or robs others of respect or perhaps
steals relationships
all these things count and our way of
saying to the universe i don't really
deserve the good in life i have to sneak
around and take it
so become aware of the beliefs that may
be blocking the flow of money in your
life
and then change those beliefs and begin
to create new abundant thinking
even if no one else in your family has
done this
you can open your mind to the concept of
money flowing into your life
if we want to prosper then we must use
prosperity thinking
i have two prosperity affirmations i've
used for many years and they work well
for me they'll also work for you
one my income is constantly increasing
and two i prosper wherever i turn
i had very little money when i started
using them but consistent practice has
made them come true for me
you know for a long time i believe that
business is a place where we bless and
prosper each other
i've never understood the concept of
cutthroat business where you try to
cheat and put one over on the other
person that doesn't sound like a joyous
way to live
there is so much abundance in this world
if we would but just share it
at hay house my publishing firm we have
always been honest honorable we live up
to our word we do our work well and
treat others with respect and generosity
when you live that way it is impossible
to keep the money away
the universe rewards you at every
possible turn
today we have a fabulous reputation in
the publishing world and so much
business that we are turning it away
we do not want to grow so big that we
lose the personal touch
now if i an abused child who did not
finish high school can do it
so can you
once a day stand with your arms open
wide and say with joy i am open and
receptive to all the good and abundance
in the universe
and thank you life
life will hear you and respond the
source of abundance
is infinite
why
because the source of every experience
is consciousness
and consciousness
is by definition non-local has no form
and therefore it's infinite
and the source of all experience is
infinite and therefore
it can never be
in short supply
so
if we think deeply about this first law
the source of abundance is infinite
then of course we want to get in touch
with that source
and that source is
our innermost being
which is the field of all possibilities
the field of unpredictability
and the source of
intention and desire the field of
that is evolving in the direction of
truth goodness beauty harmony
and love
the field that
is inexhaustible
as
a source for ongoing
creativity and abundance
and
it is simple to
get in touch with the source
by transcending the mind through
meditation
through
self-awareness
through self-reflection
through self-inquiry
through mindful awareness of
every experience mindful awareness of
body
mindful awareness of
the processes of the mind
mindful awareness of the web of
relationship
mindful awareness
of mental space
and
to engage this source of infinite
possibilities
by asking questions
and receiving answers
i've been in the habit of doing that
every day all my life
and reviewing
this process every night
before i go to sleep whatever you want
to receive start by giving so we can you
know start with simple things
if you want
attention you pay attention to others
if you want
respect
you
give respect to others
if you want
love
you give your love to
everyone
that you meet
and
respect love
attention
affection
appreciation
acceptance
a very simple things to start with
but if you want to generate wealth
then figure out a way to generate wealth
for others
and also
figure out
how you can
activate abundance consciousness in
others
and one way to do this is also
to experience gratitude so when you
experience gratitude it opens the door
to abundance consciousness
so think of all the things you're
grateful for material things
relationships
health
on and on career and as you
open the door
of
gratitude
it leads to
the realm of abundance
start with giving once in a while when
i'm in new york city i go to the bank
and i get some cash
and then i walk around the city
um
giving cash
or dollars
to homeless people on the street
and don't do it uh casually
do it sincerely look them in the eyes
talk to them
and see
their reaction when you give them 20
or whatever you'll see the gratitude in
your eyes and you feel a connection
between
spirit and spirit
and so this
exchange
by the way that's what money is also
called the exchange the currency of
exchange
so
start with that
process
and live in that process don't stop
the flow
of abundance
by holding money
if you hold money it's of no use we had
a thanksgiving where
literally we had no food and and we
wouldn't have starved but we weren't
gonna have a thanksgiving dinner
and uh there was a knock at the door and
that knock changed my life because it
was someone who delivered food for us it
was just a delivery man the person who
actually sent it
didn't acknowledge who they were and the
man said this is just a gift for you and
your family
my father didn't react very well to it
at the time
didn't want charity but a necessity took
it in and i just remember at that time
thinking to myself
why is it that my father worked so hard
because he did work he wasn't unemployed
and yet here we are with no money
on thanksgiving not even for food
and
it's just
my whole life had been that way and i
just i couldn't understand why we were
living on the other side of the tracks i
lived in what i thought was a rich
community it was actually a middle class
community lower middle class but
everybody else we live right next the
railroad tracks quite literally and
everyone seemed like living a different
lifestyle and i couldn't understand my
father i felt was as good as their
fathers as a person why did we have such
lack why was there such scarcity why did
they have so much abundance in us not
have any
and i really didn't have the answer
until i sat in that room with jim rohn
and he asked a question he said you know
what does it really take
to do well financially what does it take
to have real economic abundance
and he said you must bring value to the
marketplace i'll never forget
and i thought what the hell is he
talking about value to the marketplace
and he made it very clear that we all
have value in our own souls but that's
not what we get paid for we also get
paid for effort we don't get paid for
our time we get paid to find a way to
add value
and the question he asked at the time
was how is it possible that some people
earn twice as much money as you do or
four times or five times or ten times as
much money in the same amount of time
and he said the answer is because they
found a way to add more value
that is the secret to abundance do more
for others than anyone else on earth and
if you can do that you can build a brand
you can build a company you can build a
life you can build friendships that are
beyond compare
and so that simple little philosophy was
really simple and he went a little
deeper he was very specific he said you
know if you look at it i remember at the
time he said if you work for mcdonald's
in those days he said you make 250 an
hour
and i remember he said you know
somebody's working making 250 now and
they're barely surviving today working
mcdonald's you make eight dollars an
hour by contrast a little inflation but
this is 1977. and he said so
why do these people make so little and
somebody that he gave the example back
then of the gentleman who is the head of
disney and he's made 52 million dollars
in the same year one person's making 250
an hour somebody just makes 52 million
so how is that possible isn't that fair
isn't that unfair
and i remember at the time in pausing
and saying well anybody can learn within
an hour
how to really
do the numbers and use a cash register
in fact today you don't even know the
numbers you just push a button with a
picture on it right so anybody can do
that it's not being disrespectful so
there's not a lot of added value in fact
soon robotics will probably take most of
that over because it's it's not
something that expands the human spirit
it's not a complex task that makes us
expand or grow and offer something
but he said you know the guy that
figured out how to turn disney around
with having trouble it's worth 52
million because he's bringing joy and
happiness and love and laughter to
millions and millions of people so if
you help millions of people
you're going to do well
in the bible it says if you wish to
become great learn to become the servant
of many which as jim used to say is you
know that means there's nothing wrong
with wanting to be great
but greatness comes from serving a large
number of people or at a deep level one
of the two
and so you look at it today and today
the story is the same you work at
mcdonald's it's eight dollars an hour
and i just got finished writing a book
where i interviewed 50 of the most
successful financial people on earth
that started with nothing and you look
at a guy last year david tepper was the
highest paid hedge fund guy he got paid
3.5 billion dollars last year now that
looks like incredibly unjust experience
you know it's insane it's insane to
think that that man's going to make 3.5
and someone else is going to make 15 000
a year at 8 an hour basically how could
you justify that
well
if you find a way to add more value you
can earn more and you can be abundant he
figured a way to get a 40 return for
people
in a world where most people are putting
their money in a savings account getting
33 basis points one third of one percent
if he got people one percent return he'd
be having 300 percent more value but
he's adding 12 000 percent more value
for his investors these people have
taken their money and they're able to do
things for their families for their
businesses for the causes they care
about because he's growing at a
multiplied level because he developed
this incredible set of skills and how
did he do it the way jim rohn teaches he
learned to work harder and himself he
learned to master skills no one else had
that could add value to others
so introducing you to jim rohn and
abundance i just want to mark out that
you can earn 10 times more 20 times more
100 times more in the same amount of
time if you work harder on yourself than
anything else if you find a way to do
more for others than anyone else and
then it goes beyond money
then it goes to
understanding abundance as an emotion
like love
like joy
it's the most amazing thing the more of
it that we give the more of it we
experience inside now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated you have a 35 chance
of actually following through that's
what the science says and that is not
good enough believe nation we need to do
better when you actually get motivated
and then create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do this
week you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you publicly commit to
somebody else like leaving a comment
below on this video it jumps even higher
so i want that for you i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week so i can celebrate with you
god said joshua
keep this law book
on your lips
george was a young guy
just like you wanted to do something
good in life
god says here's the secret
keep this book of the law on your lips
meditate on it day and night
he says and be careful
to do everything
written in it
and then he says the result
is this
you will make your way
prosperous
and you will have
good success
the two things you're trying to get
are related to law
you think it's ready to you've related
to work hard working room no no no no
you can work hard and still be broke ask
the person next to you don't look right
don't look right now
[Applause]
it is hard work that does it
slaves work hard study history slaves
are hard-working people
they don't even own themselves
so working hard is not the secret
it's laws
if you keep my laws meditate talk about
them on the on your lips he says they
will what you will make your way
prosperous that means you make your own
prosperity
by what doing the laws
you only
use your car to go to work
something wrong with that
you can serve some people with your car
pick an old lady up from the jerry i
should take out every week once a week
use your car
that's there's a law
he says you will make your way
prosperous you have good success
look at jeremiah
god says
29 11.
i know the plans i have for you god says
plans to prosper you
what kind of god is this
now why does he want you to prosper
namesake
i plan for my product to prosper he says
what else
not to harm you why because my name is
on you
i can't have a broken product
that's that's bad for my reputation as a
company
you know i pray
when i have a need
i say lord this ain't good for you
i can tell everybody
and the needs keep being met
you don't pray for your sake
i have a plan he says for you
a plan to prosper you
not to harm you
i plan to give you what hope
and i got to make sure you make it
to the destiny
what's the destiny the destiny for bird
is to fly
i got to make sure you make it to flight
it's just never seed is to become a tree
with fruit i got to make sure you make
it to the fruit bearing stage i have to
make sure you make it to your end
because my name
is on the line when you get laws you can
even smell
what ain't gonna work
success is not luck
you gotta make sure you keep obeying
laws
when i counsel people i would tell them
look you violated the law
okay listen you want his marriage to
work you gotta there's some laws ain't
no magic
i can't pray if you have a good marriage
there's some laws involved in this
ain't no devil in this
you all
your american law problems
i was blaming the devil for things
[Applause]
laws
if the axe is what dull
much strength
is needed with no success
but with skill
success comes out even quickly the guy
said two minutes finish now the problem
is when he's finished
see you on prosper okay
prosperity come from what laws the guy
brought some laws to the car now he
gonna prosper
you ain't gonna prosper
you losing
if you didn't know the laws of a car
yourself
he wouldn't get your money
so you'll be prospering yourself
you take your money to a dentist
because you can't fix your teeth
you take your money to the doctor
because you can't fix your body you take
your money to the lawyer because you
can't understand the contract in other
words when a person develop their skill
you take their money to them
it's a law
so why would the nfl call me they saw a
skill
and believe me your skill is developed
for a long time without pay
just keep working on it just keep
working
sometimes you got to work with the
children first you know some of you
won't be big right away no go work in
children's church for just work on it
i learned to teach by talking to kids
who didn't know when i messed up
let me say it again you won't be a
public speaker go
teach in children's church
the kids don't know when you don't do
right
go work in the nursery talk to them
babies tell them about god they don't
know if you messing up
practice your gift at every opportunity
stop looking